you're about to see a test of the trusty automatic
parachute with the customers enjoying arrived
trouble suddenly develops presto pilot pulls a
lever and mr. passenger is floating down to earth
even if you just start going out
there's nothing to worry about the
view is better from out here anyway
and when you get tired of looking
at the scenery a slapper to either
release trigger and you're on your way
this kind of parachuting doesn't
even give you a chance to get scared
the slow motion camera shows you how simple it is
mr. trustees gadget does all the work you can keep
right on reading your newspaper if you wanna and
there you are floating serenely through the ozone
Maxton probe wood will be a regular phone
attached to every chair so you can call the
little wife to have supper ready when you land yes
sir parachute jumping is going to be the Nationals